[Music]
when he came out as an atheist
seif elbahr ii began to receive death
threats as a ticket I often get sent
free tickets to hell often they say
you'll burn you'll burn for eternity God
will punish you Satan has led you astray
or if I saw you I would kill you Muslims
make up 5% of Germany's population
before he moved here so I've called
himself a Muslim too but while studying
medicine he began to experience doubts
about his faith the Islamic world is
dominated by a kind of culture of
intimidation neither God nor the faith
is ever questioned there are strict
guidelines that have to be accepted they
aren't questioned either and that's not
on
I'm calling for independent thinking
sighs who originally came from the Iraqi
capital Baghdad now considers Islam to
be coercive he blocks about his negative
experiences and his ideas makes some
Muslims uncomfortable okay what would I
do if my child became an atheist he
would hurt me I wouldn't tolerate it but
I wouldn't punish him for it either
they'd have punished themselves enough
already you know killings and murder
threats like these have nothing to do
with religion that's the way to the
devil unfortunately it has nothing to do
with us we're sorry for those people to
their people who've been politicized and
that damages us too we're Muslims and we
don't put pressure on our children we
pray and I'd like to pass on the good
bits which I learned from my parents and
my faith but if they don't go along with
it they're free people
the minority of Muslims who do sent
death threats to people like save base
their actions on a message they
attribute to the Prophet Muhammad in the
Islamic tradition in Sunni and also
Shiite schools of thought someone who's
abandoned Islam has three days during
which he is called to repent if the
person doesn't return to Islam then
they're to be threatened with death the
content taught in detail - traffic these
days that interpretation is
controversial Mahad completer says it
sends the wrong message in various
emails being if we force someone to
pretend to be Muslims just because
they're scared of a death penalty that
would be teaching upon receipt that's
not really in the spirit of the Quran
Mina a Hadi helps young Muslims who want
to leave Islam she leads a group of 500
people who are critical of the religion
it aims to support young people whether
they want to quit Islam or convert to
another faith I'll always remember
getting a phone call from a girl who
said I still wear a headscarf even
though I'm no longer a Muslim but I
haven't spoken to my parents because
it's a really problematic issue an
estimated 10 to 15% of people raised as
Muslims either no longer practice or
convert to another religion many of them
don't tell their parents or family their
own friends and family are a major
source of their fear they're scared of
being disowned it took sighs two years
to muster up the courage to tell his
family that he had lost his faith their
reaction was not what he had expected I
was surprised that my uncles who were
really strict and conservative initially
accepted it they were surprised of
course - they tried to have a discussion
with me which i think is a positive sign
however they did patronize me on an
intellectual level claiming that Satan
had misled me and that's why I am now
cursed they've now come to accept his
point of view
sigh hopes one day the people sending
him death threats will do so too in that
respect his faith is strong